hey this is presh tolwalker
which quantity is greater sine of one
degree divided by sine of 2 degrees or
sine of 3 degrees divided by sine of 4
degrees this is a no calculator question
and I think Amit for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
foreign
before I explain the answer I want to
give a brief and simplified history
about how the word sign became to be
called sign
so it all starts with an Archer
ancient Indians thought about the bow as
an arc of a circle
we can then imagine constructing the
radius lengths of the circle and this
would be the length of the bow string
now to simplify things a little bit more
eventually they started working with
just half the cord and half this length
here
then they work with circles that had a
radius equal to one
now the length of this blue line depends
on this angle right here
and the length of this was known as ja
which referred to the length of the bow
string this is the modern equivalent of
sine and this jaw was in Sanskrit around
the year 500.
now this got translated into Arabic as
jiba
around 800.
now eventually this came to European
mathematicians and there was a corrupted
translation
so they took a word which had the same
spelling but a different pronunciation
and this word jibe refers to bosom or
pocket now that word translated
literally becomes sinus and that entered
Latin around 1100 now interestingly this
length right here was called KOJA and of
course that refers to the cosine
so with this introduction let's now
solve the problem one way to work out
the problem is to use the product to sum
formula
so we need to figure out which quantity
is greater
now since sine of two degrees is greater
than zero we can multiply both sides by
sine of 2 degrees without altering this
inequality
so we can bring it to the other side
similarly since sine of 4 degrees is
greater than zero we can multiply both
sides by sine of 4 degrees and it won't
alter which side is greater
so let's go ahead and do that
so the problem is equivalent to
comparing the product sine of 4 degrees
and sine of 1 degrees versus the product
sine of 3 degrees and sine of 2 degrees
so we can now use the product to sum
formula
sine of a multiplied by sine of B is
equal to one half of cosine of a minus B
minus cosine of a plus b
so on the left hand side a is equal to 4
degrees and 1 degrees so we can
substitute into the formula
then four plus one is equal to 5 and 4
minus 1 is equal to 3.
now we can do the same thing on the
other side so here a is equal to 3
degrees and B is equal to 2 degrees so
we substitute in
3 minus 2 is equal to 1 and 3 plus 2 is
equal to 5 so we substitute in
so we've now reduced the problem to
comparing these two quantities
now
we can multiply both sides by 2 or
cancel out the one-half without altering
which side is greater and we could add
cosine of 5 degrees to both sides
without altering which side is greater
so we just need to compare cosine of
three degrees and cosine of one degrees
but that's easy to do
so between 0 and 90 degrees cosine is a
decreasing function therefore cosine of
3 degrees is less than cosine of one
degree
so that means the left hand side was
smaller and therefore sine of one degree
divided by sine of 2 degrees is less
than sine of 3 degrees divided by sine
of 4 degrees
so that's one way to solve the problem
but another method is to use the small
angle approximation
so madhava came up with this interesting
series for sine hundreds of years before
it was in Europe sine X is equal to x
minus X cubed over 3 factorial plus x to
the power of 5 over 5 factorial minus x
to the power of 7 over 7 factorial and
so on
now this is for X in radians so if we
have a small value of x then X cubed x
to the power of 5 x to the power of 7
and so on will be very very small
numbers so this entire part of the sum
will approximately be equal to zero so
sine X will approximately be equal to X
so let's use this approximation now we
need X to be in radians and we have
degrees here so let's convert these
degrees into radians 1 degree is equal
to pi over 180 radians then 2 degrees
will be equal to 2 pi over 180 radians
so let's just simplify this left-hand
side first let's use sine X is
approximately equal to X so we have pi
over 180 divided by 2 pi over 180 the
pies and the 180s will cancel out so
this left hand side is approximately
equal to one-half
doing the same thing on the right hand
side three degrees is equal to 3 pi over
180 and 4 degrees is equal to 4 pi over
180.
so this will approximately be equal to 3
pi over 180 divided by 4 pi over 180 the
pies and the 180s cancel out so we're
left with three over four
so the left hand side is approximately
equal to 1 over 2 and the right hand
side is approximately equal to three
over four and so the left hand side is
therefore less than the right hand side
now just for fun we can use a calculator
and actually check
so the approximation is actually very
good
so that's another way to solve this very
interesting question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]